what do new screenwriters need to know
about story structure what would you
teach them how story structure that you
have to have an idea that that can can
fill let's say a screenplay many times
someone sets down to write they say I
have an idea for a script and it really
quite isn't a fully fleshed out story
with a beginning a middle and an end
and so I would say before you sit down
you can have a kernel of an idea which
blossoms into something bigger but try
to work on it where you can step back
away and get is this a movie as we know
movies you know is it going to be big
enough and there are small stories I'm
not saying that small stories aren't
movies but if you're gonna write a
feature film for you know big Hollywood
for you know 4,000 screens it may not be
this little idea you know and sometimes
even when I see an outline there's not
enough story there to facilitate 100
pages you know you think it is and
you're like well you kind of skipped
over most of the second act here you
didn't quite think through all that and
structure is extremely important so it's
screenplays are built on you know
telling the story so your story was
originally I mean your your question
about structure do you think then a lot
of people just have a great beginning
and then a fishing and then in the
middle it's very muddy yes oh it's
always muddy in the middle and the first
act is the easiest set up because it's
all set up right we're all setting up
but they're you know the thing and then
you have to go on the journey and act to
and that's where it starts to get more
difficult because like I say if you're
just winging a script it's always those
big barren wasteland in the middle
that's really you know you can know the
nd and hopefully it'll get you there I
know the ending scene fantastic you know
where you have to get but all that stuff
in between
you know that always seems to be the
issue is the is the big let's say it's
act 2 the middle the
part which is pretty much the mean
potatoes of you know the movie what has
helped you get to a better second act
well knowing the ending for sure but
also really getting to the essence and
what am I trying to do with this story
you know what I mean what's what's my
theme what is my what's this about what
you know is it just well two people on a
car ride and they drive across the
country great that could be an amazing
story but what happens what is it about
you know what's there what's the problem
what what do they have to face what to
get to that ending part and working on
an outline I hate to refer back to that
is working on the story
so you just and sometimes story you
think it's something's there and it
doesn't work you know and other times
I've done many drafts of an outline
where I couldn't find the story and I
kept trying to fight it and then I
realized that it had to do with
characters and so the story was there
the ABC and D of it but it still wasn't
working so a lot of times you can have
an idea which if the work at the idea
you have to work it into it's you know
it's full essence of what it can be and
sometimes you may want to just leave it
alone and say you know what I don't
think that's I don't think that's a
story and that I can manage together and
I'm gonna move on to something else
that's okay to do you think a lot of
people have trouble letting go of their
stories like what if it's a very
personal story well yeah well if it's
personal story it would be hard to let
go
trying to force it but then I might say
maybe it's not meant to be a screenplay
maybe it's meant to be something else
maybe a book you know or I don't know
what what it could be but and that's for
the writer to decide if it really is not
is not working and it's okay just to
move on to something else
there's no no harm no foul you know have
you done that where you're like you know
what I I love these characters but for
some reason this isn't going I mean for
things that you've written on your own
yes right uh I I have a hard time I'm so
strict about it has to be like like a
really good idea of my own that it sort
of I have this inner filter that it
limits that unfortunately so yeah many
times I've said this one just is not
it's not working and other ones you
other ones you see right away because
the characters are so vibrant and alive
and you're like yeah I can I can see
this you know this is what what it works
like I said there's no there's no harm
and maybe putting it aside to maybe
another time is you can become more
experienced writer that you can go back
to it and work on it so nothing's ever
dead you know you don't have to discard
it completely nor do I think you should
but to move on is okay as well you put
it in you know the in the notebook and
sale you know and that's how you build
ideas that's how you build a an arsenal
of stuff that you can go back and work
on keep your well and your creative well
full you know you've also talked about
just living life yes well - how do you
know when aside from not being on an
assignment that it's time to go and fill
the well who's I know that the life
behind the computer can get very one no
show at all yes I I hate sitting at the
keyboard it may say that it's a
necessity but you also have to live your
life and like we're talking about that
you know an authentic life outside your
comfort zone is a good thing you know do
things that you're afraid of and I mean
jump off a cliff but I was skydiving
once you know and that was one time only
but it wasn't just to go
oh I mean some people were going and and
they said hey you want to come and I'm
like yeah I do
and it's not something I would ever do
again and I'm not a daredevil type
person but it was amazing experience and
those kind of experiences you know you
can write into your projects where it's
not just you're living in a little
protective bubble where you're writing
stuff that you've seen on television or
movie
we're just regurgitating which could be
cliches to begin with which probably are
you know that that's where your own
personal experience comes into
characters and and your unique voice and
things because I've lived it I went to
blah blah blah I've been you know I've
been there you know type of thing so
yeah writers should have interesting
lives if possible you know because I was
watching a master class with David
Sedaris oh yes it's hilarious and he
picks up garbage I guess around the
little town that he lives in Wow and he
says that you know he wears his best and
he does it and people don't realize a
lot of times that he's this writer this
author and sure so sometimes they'll be
like oh sir you actually missed a piece
over here and he goes with it yeah and
he says I would have this is this gets
me out
this is where I'm able to see people in
a ways that I wouldn't see them right
when I'm speaking French they aren't
gonna talk to me like that you know and
he goes with it and he and he oh yeah
sure sorry about that and so that's part
of his way he's doing a good thing
and he also gets out and interacts with
people and he's he's observing life too
you know as a actor a writer
it's good to observe the world around
you get off the phone you know and
actually go oh my gosh that's interest
this is real life out here you know this
interesting character or oh I heard that
little at the coffee shop that person
said that thing you know write it down
in your notebook these are these are
cool little things you can start
building upon it's been it's part of
your job to be an observer as well as an
adventurer you know I think so I mean I
don't mean you know take off quit your
job and you know sail across the world
if that's your thing but you can do it
like you say with small things that just
kind of different like yeah well
normally wouldn't do that and don't be
afraid to try that because it all will
it all will filter back hopefully into
your work you know what you're writing
so when someone reads something it won't
be I saw this scene in last week on
television you know or you know what I
mean it's sort of like different and
fresh unique because it's it's personal
it's a personal experience yeah it feels
like in some ways there's less places to
go these days you know a lot of
bookstores aren't around
yes I know and that used to be one place
where you could just get out you know
yes and yeah you can go to a coffee shop
and there's some great ones what people
are also busy with headphones on German
they're all doing their own thing you
know not sort of like I'm in my own
little world you're in your right world
you know
yeah but it is helpful because you just
don't know me well aside from from maybe
vacations or something what are some
other things you do to get yourself out
of that we'll just try to get out in the
world you know try to yeah I tend to be
an introvert sometimes when I'm working
so then you got to be like get out of
there you know go go it's not like it
hasn't been done in the past obviously
but you have to you have to keep
yourself in check that you don't it
doesn't become like you know 80/20 of 80
introvert 20 you know when it was more
before because it can slip very easily
that way were you like uh I don't want
to go out I want to do this thing just
being around people too good bad and
different whatever sure no yeah I see
all sorts of stuff out there yeah you
know was it Jackie Gleason who said his
advice for like people than the industry
was get out like don't be a shut-in and
also I think get out of the business you
know kiss Hollywood is like this weird
little place where everybody your round
is talking about the business you know
anyway
is there anybody saving lives here at
this party do we have a doctor or
something you know I mean let me know at
times it really is like okay you know
and we all want to congregate together
because everybody's bibbidi bobbidi
network but many times is really great
you know some big actor and remember is
his best friends are not even in the
business they're just you know people
not in the film business and you're like
yeah that's refreshing
you know I have both both you know in
and out you know so it's good to have a
nice mix but if you're just around that
only it's sort of like this fake world
you know kind of things